the conflict in ethiopia continues in
the north of the country since it began
over a year ago
a battle for political power has turned
into a bloody contest and a war which is
now spreading through large parts of the
country opposition fighters are pushing
south in some places as close as 220
kilometers from the capital addis ababa
lost in the conflict the local
population suffers from violence and
hunger an estimated 2.5 million people
were already displaced from their homes
from the ethiopian capital of addis
ababa sky news's africa correspondent
john sparks has this update and a
warning that his report includes images
of some of the injuries sustained
there is a place in addis ababa with
orange flowers and a big red wall
a quiet spot in this uneasy city for a
five-year-old who loves to draw
her name is kiddist
and she is the victim of a brutal war
with scars that will never leave her
her sisters were also injured when a
shell exploded next to them late last
year
nine-year-old bethlehem lost her
achilles tendon and the wound still
weeps
fourteen-year-old yodanus has lost much
of her left leg
while the eldest seventeen-year-old
abuba has had part of her right leg
amputated
it hurts does it it still causes you
pain
the war in ethiopia is waged with little
knowledge of the cost
the number of dead injured or missing
are seemingly unknown
but the impact on the jigsaw family has
been calamitous
do you think about the war
no
but i'm not going
[Music]
nobody knows who fired the shell that
destroyed the family home
government soldiers anti-gray and rebels
were fighting nearby
but this bed sit in the capital feels
much safer
it may be temporary and it is certainly
cramped but the jigsaw girls have each
other
who's the boss
is the boss
they're looked after by their uncle a
teacher called calaiu
he found them in the back of an army
truck in a place called desi a week or
so after the attack
it's difficult when you see they are
bleeded they are
into the cries
it's very difficult
i saw them
on the car
so
i pulled up here
i saw them
it's also very
the morning routine is a complicated
affair
bethlehem's bandages need changing every
two days and her uncle helps to dress
the wounds
but there was not much he could do for
udanis who was unable to get out of bed
will you go to school today
um
[Music]
her siblings know this pain
but they have to get themselves ready
for school
kittist needs these braces because her
feet were damaged in the explosion
and calais does what he can
their mother was killed by the artillery
shell
and they haven't seen their father for
months
now you are the father of
four girls yeah
yeah god made these things
when they are going to school when i
i see her
the children the kids face
when they are happy when they are
getting a nice mark from
the exam
just this is what a father can do
the jigsaw children are outsiders here
ethnic to grahams who've taken shelter
in a mistrustful city
and soon they'll need a new place to
live
assistance from an ngo has almost run
out
but this family will find strength in
each other
john sparks sky news in addis ababa